-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor
who you know
from "Difficult People,"
"American Horror Story"
and "Billy on the Street."
He co-wrote and stars
in the new movie "Bros,"
which premieres in theaters
September 30th.
Let's take a look.
-I woke up laughing about
you so rudely calling me out
on my [bleep].
-Well, you deserved it, bitch.
Honestly, I was impressed.
You may be more emotionally
unavailable than I am.
-Well, maybe we can be
emotionally unavailable
together.
-Maybe we can be emotionally
unavailable together?
Who's writing your texts,
Maroon 5?
-[Bleep] off.
-Kidding. We can go out.
Are you asking me out?
-I'm down for whatever.
-Yeah, same.
-Cool.
-Sounds good.
-So, tomorrow?
Or we can do whenever.
-Yeah, I can do whenever
and I can do whatever.
-I don't care what we do.
-Yeah, me neither.
We can do whatever
and we can do it whenever.
Does that work for you?
-Yeah, that definitely works.
-Great. Whatever, whenever.
-Cool. Whatever, whenever.
Gif of Michael Scott dancing.
That's good.
-"Office" gif?
This person isn't gay.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to
the show, our very good friend,
the one, the only Billy Eichner,
everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Billy, welcome back!
-What's up, New York?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hi.
-What an exciting time
to be sitting here next to you.
You co-wrote this film.
-Yeah.
-You star in this film.
-And this then is a rom-com
where, you know,
the leads are two gay men.
-Mm-hmm.
-Give us a little synopsis for
anybody who might not know.
-"Bros" is the first
gay rom-com ever released
by a major studio.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, and it's also produced
by Judd Apatow and co-written
with Nick Stoler.
Those guys have made some
of the funniest movies ever --
"Bridesmaids,"
and "40-year-Old Virgin,"
and "Knocked Up,"
and "Train Wreck,"
and "Forgetting Sarah Marshall."
But, this is the first time
they've ever made a movie
like that,
but about a gay couple.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
And it is long overdue,
but I'm so excited about it.
And it's basically about --
I play Bobby Leiber,
who's a podcaster
at the beginning of the movie
and then gets a job working on
the board of what will be
the first LGBTQ history museum
in New York City,
which leads to a lot of
infighting among various members
of my community.
-[ Laughs ]
And then Bobby's a guy
who prides himself
on not needing anyone,
not wanting to be in a romantic
relationship.
And then he meets Aaron,
who he was texting with,
played by the wonderful
Luke McFarland --
-He's fantastic in the film.
-Who's so good in the movie.
-And they're both guys,
they've have been out
their whole lives,
they're very sexually active,
but both of them --
it is almost like
they're in a competition to see
who can be
more emotionally unavailable.
-[ Laughs ]
-Right?
And, though --
But they fall for each other.
They fall in love unexpectedly.
And we watch these two guys
who really pride themselves
on not needing love
fall in love
and what happens when they have
to let their guard down.
-You know, I was telling you
backstage,
it works so wonderfully as
a super funny rom-com.
-Yeah, thank you.
-Like, it has all
of the classic elements
you love.
And then, every now and then,
there's moments
where you remember
that it's also historic
in the fact
that it's covering something
that's never been covered.
You've been doing screenings
all over the country.
-Yeah.
-You went to TIFF.
At those screenings,
do you feel the audience
is having that reaction as well?
It must be so important
to people.
-It's -- Yeah, yeah.
TIFF is the Toronto
International Film Festival,
which usually doesn't
take romantic comedies
like this, you know?
-Yeah.
-And that was amazing. And
what's also incredible is that,
you know, Nick and I --
you don't sit down
to write a historic scene.
-Sure.
-You don't sit down to write
a gay movie.
We just wanted to make
a hilarious movie.
And think what we've forgotten
partially because of COVID --
it's just, we don't get
many comedies like this
in a movie theater anymore,
you know?
I don't know why.
I grew up loving
"When Harry Met Sally,"
and "Moonstruck,"
and "Sleepless in Seattle"
and "You've Got Mail"
and, you know,
all these great movies,
and I think people have
forgotten how much fun
it is to sit in a movie
theater with hundreds
of other people
and laugh together.
You know, it really is --
it's a feel-good movie and --
that's such
a joyful experience,
and I'm so glad "Bros" will give
that to people again.
-And having written it,
I'm assuming you pulled a lot
from your own
personal experiences.
What were things from your
own life that were important
for you to get into the script?
-Oh, God. I mean, all that
passive aggressive stuff
over texting.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-You know, I mean, this is what
I mean.
Like, we've had audiences
who are mostly straight
watch the movie.
We've had audiences
that are more LGBTQ,
but these are things
anyone who's ever been single
in the past 15 years
can relate to.
-Yeah.
-You know, because dating apps
and texting and sexting --
it's driving everyone crazy.
Because it's allowed everyone
to be passive aggressive
and noncommittal,
and it's driven me insane many
times with guys like the one
that Luke plays in the movie.
-But this --
Is this true, that you've got --
you've been kicked off
Tinder twice?
-Yes, Seth, I have.
-[ Laughs ]
-I not only -- I'm not only the
maker of the first gay rom-com
from a major studio,
I've also been kicked off
of Tinder twice.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Which is hard to do.
They're pretty forgiving.
-Let me --
-[ Laughs ]
-Let me explain why.
I didn't do anything wrong.
You know,
I'm like everyone else.
I'm just trying to be a normal
person, like, meeting people.
So I join Tinder,
but then people recognize me.
They don't think it's me.
They think it's someone
pretending to be me, right?
So, they report my account.
And Tinder thought they were
doing the right thing
and they booted me twice.
And then I complained
about it,
and then they sent me
a care package.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine how depressing it is
when you're
a 44-year-old single man
getting a care package
from Tinder.
-Yeah.
-That had literally a T-shirt
that said
"World's Greatest Single."
[ Laughter ]
There was like a mug that was
like "Single, But Loving It."
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, with, like --
and by the way, you know,
shout out to Tinder.
The thought was very nice,
but it was honestly
the most depressing gift
I've ever received.
[ Laughter ]
And "Bros" very much draws on
experiences like that.
-I have a lot more to
ask you.
We will be right back with more
from Billy Eichner after this.